well we've got several Senate seats
being called and here's how the senate
race is shaping up we've got Democrats
they're at 41 seats Republicans are at
40. there's only 35 seats up for grabs
the Democrats started at 36 and
Republicans started at 29 so they've
actually taken more in these early hours
of voting let's take a closer look now
at the Georgia Senate race that's really
getting tight Raphael wore not the
incumbent there against Herschel Walker
66 of the votes counted and it's looking
neck and neck remember they have to one
of those candidates have to pass 50 to
prevent a runoff in December there so we
might not get any results from that for
quite a while now some very early
results are coming from another key
Battleground State that's of
Pennsylvania only 38 of votes counted
but we are seeing John fetterman for the
Democrats pulling slightly ahead of
moment odds but only 38 of the votes
counted so that's far too early to call
there let's go to Texas the governor
race there in Texas Beto O'Rourke he's
trying to unseat Greg Abbott the very
Republican
anti-abortion anti-gun control Governor
the anti-immigration governor he's
pulling ahead with
53.69 but again early days there only 53
of the vote counted too early to call
well let's take a look at the races in
the House of Representatives there we've
got 435 seats up for grabs now this is
the lower
chamber of Congress this is the
legislative body and this is where the
Republicans are predicted to pull ahead
and take control from the Democrats who
had a very slim lead before the magic
number there to reach is
218 that we've got Republicans sitting
on 86 Democrats on 47 not indicative of
tall of what's going to happen there
later in the night let's go to Alan
Fisher because he's keeping much more
across the house races than I am able to
hear and I'm sure you've got some
updates for us there Alan
some really interesting results coming
out you remember at the start of the
evening we said there were a number of
seats you need to keep an eye on if the
Democrats lose them then there's every
possibility that this Red Wave the
Republican Red Wave is going to
materialize well some bad news for the
Republicans Jennifer Wexler in Loudoun
County just outside Washington DC she
has won our seat Abigail spamberger down
again in Virginia down in Culpeper
County and around that area there she is
almost certainly going to win the seat
they are not officially confirmed but is
ahead of our our Republican Challenger
yesterday Vega and Maggie Hassan who was
at risk of losing her senate seat in New
Hampshire is doing much better than
anyone expected winning places that last
time round when she ran for the Senate
she she lost so she's turned that right
around so she's doing very well also
here's a name that you'll know Alexandra
Acacia Cortez or one of the the leaders
of the so-called Squad Award of people
who are considered to be radical
Democrats in the house she is on target
to win her seat in New York that was
expected and what is interesting too
when a lot of people are talking about
how abortion played a key part in many
of the votes and and how they were
viewing whether or not they'd vote for
the Democrats in Vermont this evening
they have enshrined the right to
abortion in the state's Constitution
that has passed on a vote that was on
the ballot in Vermont so that will now
go into the the state's Constitution so
a few interesting races one other one to
point out in North Carolina the senate
race was considered to be the open
Senate see Richard Burr retired he was a
republican that was expected to be a
safe Republican seat and certainly early
on they were saying it looked as if Ted
Bud the Republican was going to win that
seat that has now been moved into too
close to call so that suggests that the
Democrats are doing much better there
than expected and overall that will give
the Democrats some hope that perhaps the
polls were really wrong and they are
going to do much better than they were
than expected now just talking about how
she is very briefly before we go to
remember when Barack Obama was in his
first term in the midterms he lost 63
House Seats Donald Trump lost 41. both
of them were considering quite a
hammering the polls were predicting Joe
Biden might lose around 25 but he's
doing better than expected winning seats
that the the Republicans really needed
to win to make sure that this Red Wave
wasn't just something they talked about
but was actually a thing okay Alan
thanks very much for bringing us the
view there on the House of
Representatives Republicans have been
dominating Florida tonight with Rhonda
Santos re-elected as governor and Marco
Rubio getting another term in the Senate
they've been reacting over the past hour
and we're expecting Donald Trump to
react now he's just about speak from
Mar-A-Lago in Florida
some races that are hot and heavy and
we're all watching them here and some of
you like the music so much and you'd
rather hear the music and I understand
that very well
so we're doing combinations of both I'd
like to welcome the fake news media
which is back there
[Applause]
that's incredible that's a big group
they must be expecting something big
tonight actually they were hoping for
big losses but that's not happening so
um the numbers have been amazing so far
now this is just up until this point
but as of this moment on endorsements
with the nominations we had a total of
330
endorsements or nominations this is only
a nominations decision for tonight and
of the 330 we won 200 we won 324.
so if you think 224 and some of those
were long shots in all fairness they
were down in fifth place we had a lot of
people in fifth place that went to first
but it was 224 out of 330 and that's uh
that's a pretty good number and then
tonight because they kept saying well
he's good on nominations but is he good
on the general election so as of this
moment
and we have some out there we are 80
wins and three losses is that good
wouldn't that be funny if we were better
on the general election than the
nominations themselves so that's great
now North Carolina just out Ted Budd is
now leading doing great he's leading
51-47
in Missouri very good guy Eric Schmidt
is now up
55-43 and he's
he's against a bush but a different Bush
it's called
an Anheuser-Busch
that's a different bush
you tell me which is the real bush
[Music]
in Ohio JD Vance is now leading 52-47
[Music]
and we had an incredible rally last
night in Ohio
and you saw that in Florida Marco Rubio
we had an unbelievable rally for Marco
the night before with the heaviest rain
I've ever been involved with I was up
there it was beautiful everything this
is the tropics right Florida it was so
beautiful his most beautiful night and
all of a sudden it turned deadly dark
and it was like you had massive pails of
water that just fell on top of me we
went through the worst storm but we
gutted it out I had no teleprompters we
had 45
000 people out there we had no
teleprompter
and I said I wonder what Biden would do
right now but we we gutted it out
and it was amazing but Marco had a
fantastic evening at 58
to 41 that's really that's really
tremendous that's as of this moment
Katie Britt I want to congratulate Katie
Britt we endorse Katie and she did
fantastically 68 to 30. that means she
has a future young and just a fantastic
woman with a husband who's great he was
he's maybe the largest human being I've
ever seen he was a offensive lineman in
the NFL for a long time and a great
football player actually played for
Alabama but Katie congratulations to you
and we have a lot of other good ones
going out there herschel's leading right
now
so we have a lot of uh a lot of big
races going on right now so enjoy that
enjoy the food and enjoy everything and
really you know Fair it is a great honor
to have the media with us and we hope
you enjoy yourself and uh we're going to
leave uh president Donald Trump speaking
at Mar-A-Lago in Florida let's bring in
John hendren he's live in Atlanta in
Georgia I made the little gaffe there
calling him president of course we're
all expecting him to announce a run for
the 2024 presidential election uh not
done it yet and of course tonight
tonight is not really about President
Trump ex-president Trump anyway uh he is
talking all about his successes about
the Republican successes but is other
Republicans doing as well as he says
they are outside of Florida
well it does seem like they're not
having a bad night so far uh Herschel
Walker was endorsed by Trump the
Republican running in this race here in
Georgia he was endorsed by Trump he's a
good friend of trumpian folks Trump's
name often and he's neck and neck with
this sitting Senator Rafael Warnock the
Democrat who won here in a special
election just a little over a year ago
in January 2021. so those Trump
endorsements you heard him bragging
about them they do seem to matter among
Republican voters uh he hasn't foot
Herschel Walker over the top yet in
Georgia that's for voters to decide but
he seems to have had a relatively good
night you heard Trump bragging that he
was in in his count 80 versus three he
was had 80 endorsements where they
succeeded tonight and three where they
have it well we'll see what happens with
this big senate election here there are
others he did not you'll notice congrats
congratulate Ron DeSantis that for
winning the governorship of Florida one
good reason for that is that DeSantis
has already not promised that he was
going to serve out his entire term
because he is considered a leading
candidate for the presidency for the
Republican nomination for the presidency
in 2024 and that would mean if Trump
announces that he will run his main
rival at this point anyway would seem to
be Ron DeSantis so hard to say what will
happen with that but it's notable that
Trump didn't congratulate him
uh it's good good news that you've got
some earphones on there John because
it's pretty noisy isn't it that party is
determined to keep going even though we
haven't got a clear winner yet in the
senate race tell us a little bit about
the governor's race so we've got Stacey
Abrams uh attempting at a rematch
against Brian Kemp who's coming out on
top there
[Music]
has really outperformed even the polls
ahead of time Stacy Abrams is actually
running behind where she ran last time
around this is a rematch race so it's
not terribly surprising that this race
might be closed here the Warnock Walker
race the Abrams race and against uh
Brian Kemp seems to be going about as we
expected so
what we're seeing in Georgia is
different than what we've seen in
Florida in Florida we've seen blowout
margins larger than the polls ahead of
the election and hear what we're seeing
so far is about what we expected when
you look at the Herschel Walker versus
uh Rafael Warnock race that is neck and
neck which is what we expected and if it
can if it were to be called at this
point with over 70 of the vote counted
they'd have to do a rematch in December
interestingly in that race there is an
in independent a Libertarian who's
getting about two percent of the vote
one would normally expect that the
libertarian vote would come at the
expense of the Republican so it is
possible the Republicans here are even
outperforming but so far we're not
really seeing that in Florida we
certainly are but it's yet to be
determined here and it could be a long
night it could be another a couple of
weeks if there is a rematch here
indeed it does okay John thanks very
much for the moment for joining us there
from Georgia let's go back now to
Washington DC there Patty culhane is
hosting her panel of guests for more
lively discussion Patty
thanks so much Laura there is so much to
talk to about it it's just we're just in
the middle of it so I want to introduce
my guests joining me now is Jennifer
Victor professor of political science at
George Mason University ashad Hassan a
democratic Democratic strategist and
Jocelyn Jocelyn Castillo she's a
Republican strategist so we just heard
the voice of Donald Trump doing what we
all expected Donald Trump to do is take
pretty much credit for this uh this
election I want to talk first about some
of the Trump back candidates so in a
normal Universe Herschel Walker who is a
football player who didn't live in that
state necessarily goes to Georgia has
one of the worst debates can't really
even seem to speak then it comes out
that he's got domestic violence
allegations very credible ones then it
comes out that he's allegedly paid for
not one but two abortions
and he might win against he might win
evangelicals against Rafael Warnock
who's an actual preacher
so ashad to you what what
really what I mean this is an indication
that this is in addition to two you know
to two candles 24 Senate this is a
national election so the issues that the
Democratic party the Republican Party
are talking about are really sort of the
issues that people talk about generally
Americans will talk a lot in the media
in particular we'll talk a lot about
character issues but when it comes time
to vote of the polls Americans think
about okay which direction do I want to
take this country and Georgia is going
to be an excellent example of two very
different Visions for who this country
is who we are and what it is we value
and cherish so sure uh Walker is
certainly a non-traditional candidate
not by any measure a particularly strong
candidate non-traditional is it yeah
that's a that's one word for it yeah but
he is running in a very Republican state
remember we just turned Georgia Blue
this last cycle
before that it was it was Republican for
decades so sure there's going to be
plenty of Republicans who are going to
vote just as they have been voting for a
very long time and that is going to have
not much to do with the fact that Walker
isn't particularly competent on a debate
stage or that Walker has a lot of
skeletons in his closet is going to have
more to do with the anxieties that
voters have and the way that Republicans
have been able to capitalize on those
less about Walker Jocelyn you're a
republican do you look at Herschel
Walker go that's my guy
well you know I think you made a good
point Republicans have had that state in
the bag and you know in the last
election uh that was an anomaly uh and
so when you look at uh the growing
population in Atlanta that is becoming
obviously uh more uh of a blue State
these days how much is the Latino vote
uh the independent vote going to go for
a walker not necessarily because of the
candidate themselves but the issues that
he is presenting we talked about
inflation in your last segment I think
that is front of mind for a lot of
Voters we're talking about the rise and
crime
um I think people want to change they're
paying more getting less and who is the
candidate at the end of the day that is
going to vote for the right policies
inform the coalitions in Congress to get
the majorities that we need to pursue
the policies that voters want to see and
I think some voters may be able to see
Walker as a vehicle for that but as a
republican are you proud that he's your
candidate
I think I'm proud of anybody that will
pursue the right policies uh obviously
you know I think primaries have been
very tough uh in in certain Republican
states you look at Missouri for instance
Eric Schmitz was able to pull it off uh
but you know oftentimes there there is
that desire to pull a little bit more to
the right and I think when you're
looking at National contests and
Statewide contests you do want a
candidate that is able to win a
Statewide race uh do I wish that you
know we were in a position where that
state could be called within the first
10 minutes obviously but ultimately I
think that what we want is the
majorities in Congress to be able to
pursue the policies that we need which
is to stop spending to stop the bleeding
and to be able to get back on a fiscal
um you know sustainability path and I
think Walker can be that candidate once
he gets here if that's that's what
happens tonight Jennifer what does this
say to you about the future of the
Republican Party
well so I think what we're seeing is
that for a lot of Americans your party
ID your partisanship is an increasingly
important part of your identity you know
20 years ago if you ask people to
describe the most important
characteristics that describe who they
are they might talk about their gender
their religion maybe their occupation or
where they're from region or something
like that but these days increasingly it
partisanship is right up there and
because partisanship is such an
important critical part about how people
see themselves about who they identify
as being on their team or in their safe
space and who is dangerous to them
it makes it a lot easier to make a lot
of excuses for maybe people that you
wouldn't have made excuses for before in
that sense is this the post post shame
period of American politics I mean maybe
okay okay I mentioned earlier the
covered the Bill Clinton rally one of my
first as a young Cub reporter yes I'm
very old I know you're all doing the
math he was almost downed by the fact
that he said he inhaled a joint or he
smoked a joint but he didn't inhale it
so how do you go from that
to the tape from Donald Trump to now
these candidates who are like yes
there's credible allegations that he
beat his wife and paid for abortions and
he still gets the Republican vote so
what is that go ahead you wanna well I
would just I think it it's down to one's
own partisans to do the disciplining
right so we have seen some people taken
down for Scandal over the last 10 years
but they've been taken down by their own
party not by the other party they were
all Democrats
yes so for example if you have Al
Franken uh the Democratic party asked
him or pressured him to cut it out and
get out of here you don't have that same
kind of part you don't have that same
kind of pressure on the Republican side
and that's something that many Democrats
sort of talk about and fret about
but for those same Democrats it is
important that we stick to our values
and I think the Georgians get to make
that decision now
in in Georgia whether or not to stick to
their own values if those poor personal
convictions are really important to them
here's one thing I do have some hope for
as we're talking about like partisan ID
is so important as well as other
identifications I do still think there
is room for finding common ground in
common values that we all share
and I'm not saying this because I'm
being you know pollyanish or super
optimistic I'm saying this because I'm
actually worried about this we do often
find common ground in values but often
when divisiveness becomes a political
strategy it separates us rather than
unites us absolutely and when you have
people like Ron DeSantis running
policies and running stunts that are met
meant to be divisive then we lose track
of the fact that we do all of us
Americans want to be in a position where
we can be prosperous and provide for our
families we do all As Americans want to
be safe in our homes and communities and
schools that is true but then when you
have people like Donald Trump running to
say that some of these Americans are
cheaters some of these Americans aren't
even actually Americans and many of
these Americans are secretly conspiring
against you
then it erodes our ability to find
common ground with each other
seems
important to remember to point out that
there was a democratic move in the
primaries to bolster up these Trump
candidates so there's been a lot of
criticism that they said oh these
candidates are a threat to democracy but
for example in the Democrat uh Maryland
uh Governor's race they propped up the
the Republican had spent like twenty one
thousand dollars on ads and the
Democrats spent 1.2 million being like
or 1.15 million being like he's Donald
Trump's choice he's too dangerous and so
then he gets the nomination
um just if if this is the party of trump
how would you ever do what Asha just
said which is figure that figure our way
back
I mean I you're looking at Kurt Schrader
uh in Oregon not coming back uh and you
know I think the demo the the moderates
in both parties are are being filtered
out uh and that is not to uh that's to
the detriment of our institutions and so
you pointed out Democrats in the
Democratic machine spending money
against Republicans that actually work
across the aisle look at Peter Meyer in
Michigan uh that was the member that
came here to actually talk about
civility uh voted with Democrats a great
percentage of the time uh and they
ousted him they spent a great amount of
money to do that and so I think there's
a bit of hypocriticism happening on on
both sides and you know at the end of
the day the louder voices are are
starting to take hold and I think that
this election is going to show us just
how tired voters are I think on both
sides frankly when it comes to
catering to the more radical you know
smallest margins of their base people
want solutions they want to put food on
the table they want to be safe they want
members to work together they sent
Washington with a 50 50 Senate majority
less Congress and instead this
Administration in Congress pushed
through with a Reconciliation bill on a
partisan basis to try to do away with
the filibuster to try to you know
increase the number of Supreme Court
Justices that's not the Mandate that
they had to try to increase the number
of supreme Supreme Court Justices there
was talk of it they didn't actually do
it but I don't know if we were on a wide
shot or if you could see these two faces
over here they were both
can we not pretend that this is both
sides
because this isn't the same the
Democratic party and the Republican
Party are not mirror images of each
other Democrats I don't have moderates
but we have conservatives Senators like
mansion and Cinema who have
extraordinarily say within their own
party and determine the direction of
policy just as we have people like
Alexandria ocasio-cortez the Republican
party is far more uniform not just in
terms of how it is ideologically but how
it is demographically let us not
underestimate the fact or or sort of
let's not forget the fact that the
Republican Party relies overwhelmingly
on one type one race of Americans to
come out to vote and that's when it
becomes divisive like this it rips apart
the shared values the shared fabrics and
that's where you have this kind of
extremism there will always be primaries
on both sides and I'm Progressive so I'm
going to make sure that my side is
represented in the Democratic party but
I'm not calling to question the
legitimacy of the election and having
practically the entire uh you know
Congressional Delegation of my of my
side saying yeah yeah yeah this isn't
there we don't we don't really have a
president Jennifer you made a face and I
am going to get to you but guess who's
talking who have we all been talking
about Herschel Walker oh boy he's
talking and we are going to our audience
now it's perfect right see for
yourselves what we were talking about
here you go Christian Walker speaking in
Georgia
and I want to thank you guys for coming
out
thank you guys for being here and thank
you guys for all your support I'm not
leaving
I'm up there they call it a war room and
I said it's a blessing
I'm up there in this room that I've been
blessed
so I'm I'm ready and I know you guys are
ready as well so hey God bless you guys
let's just keep it going God bless thank
you guys so much
Natasha walker uh speaking uh in Georgia
let's go to the White House our
correspondent Mike Hannah these midterms
they really are a referendum aren't they
Mike on Biden on the administration on
the past two years what's America saying
well every time in the midterms yes it
is a referendum on the current
Administration whether that
Administration likes it or not President
Biden has been attempting to steer the
conversation away from that particular
fact as have his fellow Democrats but
traditionally and every term yes it is a
referendum on the administration and
what the administration has achieved now
certainly the Biden Administration has
had an up and down year at the beginning
of this year President Biden's opinion
ratings were exceedingly low sinking in
the face of increasing prices increasing
gas shortages increasing prices of gas
of rentals of accommodation Rising
interest rates and certainly at that
particular stage the Republicans were
thinking they are going to take it all
in these midterm elections but then
there was something of a comeback by the
administration they succeeded in passing
some exceedingly significant legislation
President Biden and his advisors managed
to push back the price of gas which
dropped significantly so they did pull
it back to a certain degree but the
question is whether the people of
America think that and that is what the
results are going to show in the course
of the evening individual items that are
and factor in these elections obviously
uh the Roe v wave decision by the
Supreme Court did to a certain extent
galvanized voters in many areas there
was a massive up tactic in the terms of
boaters who are registered in the wake
of that particular vote but generally in
the end what it is you quite correctly
say is a referendum on the
administration and the two years it's
been in power Mike thanks very much
we're going to go straight now to
Vermont where we are listening to we can
listen to Becca ballant she's the
representative who's been elected there
in Vermont foreign
County senate seat for the first time
because I refused to accept that the
richest nation in the world
that the richest nation in the world
could not take care of Working Families
could not house them could not feed them
could not give them Health Care
I had kids in my own classroom who I
know were were living in tents or in
cars
whose parents were struggling with
addiction
still believed
that we have to turn towards each other
in our communities that's how
that's how we're going to find our way
through
for each other
and for our communities
when we started out in this race we were
down in the polls
we didn't have a lot of money
we didn't have a lot of endorsements
but we never stopped believing that if
we pulled people together
and ran an authentic genuine race where
people could see what I was about
that they would come to us
because they wanted something different
[Applause]
this campaign is
proof that incredible power of
connection
we are craving it
We're a nation that is fraught with
loneliness and disconnection
this campaign renewed My Hope
in the power and the spirit that comes
from truly seeing one another
that's a backup balance who's just been
elected as the house representative in
Vermont that is the state Vermont
State's first woman that they are
sending to Congress she's also a member
of the lgbtq plus Community but many
glass ceilings have been broken tonight
we've also got the Massachusetts
governor race the first elected female
governor there from also the lgbtq plus
community and that's Maura Healy she's a
Democrat she beat Jeff deal he's
Republican
Arkansas governor race was also the
first woman to lead the state Sarah
Huckabee Sanders you might recognize her
as the former White House Press
Secretary under Donald Trump she beat
Chris Jones very convincingly there and
Maryland will get its first black
Governor where's Moore he's a Democrat
that is the projected winner there
running against Dan Cox the Republican
All Eyes still on the key Battleground
state of Pennsylvania however Dr mehmed
Oz the Republican television celebrity
would be the first Senator Muslim
Senator if he wins against John
fetterman he's the Democrat but with
only just over half the votes counted
it's looking pretty close there too
close to call that is a race that may
take a number of days to get the results
from let's take an overall look at the
senate race this is the map of the
United States we've got Republicans
being projected winners in all the red
Senate races we've got Missouri Kansas
North and South Dakota Florida Arkansas
two Oklahoma Senate seats Indiana
Kentucky Alabama and South Carolina
Democrats are projected winners in New
York Illinois Connecticut Maryland and
Vermont
let's bring in Maya Barry she's
executive director of the Arab American
Institute and a representative at yellow
vote that's a voter mobilization
organization she joins us from
Washington DC now I know you want to
talk about mobilization of voting and we
will get on to it first of all we've got
to address that we're seeing some firsts
tonight aren't we in The Ballot Box
we are that's always exciting to see um
I think when we make some groundbreaking
moves and I'm I'm a Maryland voter so
seeing our first African-American
elected to Governor is certainly
exciting
what do you think of the vote overall do
you think it's going according to how
the polls suggested that it was going to
um no I think perhaps the only place
that that's what's playing out today is
is Florida
um the rest of the country I think most
political pundits were smart enough to
say
um this idea of a red wave it was is a
little too early to predict
um if you looked at the polling going
into the election day most of it was
within the margin of error so frankly
you know at a certain point it didn't
become useful exercise to continue to
look at the polling
um it is close and I don't think we're
going to know the results of of all of
these races tonight
how does your organization work how do
you get people to mobilize the vote
because this has been a key issue uh for
quite a few governments Stacey Abram
want to be Governor Stacey Abrams is
talking about voter suppression she's
been key at leading people who feel
disenfranchised to The Ballot Box how
easy is it how do you go about it
well I mean it's a it's a really
interesting question because we launched
dealer vote back in 1998 and it was
specifically a voter engagement project
and it is as you said just reminding
people that you have to get out the vote
you have to go and make sure it properly
participate in your democracy you are
voting and at that time and for
certainly well over a decade into that
it was mostly about turning out the vote
regrettably as we've seen more recently
that the voter engagement efforts cannot
just be about making sure you go vote we
have to deal with a lot of voter
suppression issues that have been taking
place we have to deal with a lot of
disinformation that's been taking place
so what used to be just turning out
voters is now a lot of voter education
to tell them that some of the things
that are surfacing in their social media
feeds among their their sort of
bifurcated media Outlets are not
necessarily what what is factual and we
do a lot of work having to say this is
true this is not true please stay the
course and continue to participate in
the process and our to be clear are
we're nonpartisan institutions so my I
don't necessarily care which way a voter
votes I just want to make sure they're
engaged in the process and participating
getting voters to The Ballot Box is one
thing what about uh the situation
afterwards we've got a record number of
people who are election deniers we call
them now on the ballot how much of a
problem is this
that is a huge problem I cannot
understand the problem of going into a
midterm election with roughly 300 people
who do not believe the election of 2020
was decided accurately so when you talk
about election deniers you're talking
about people who do not acknowledge the
Integrity of the political process it's
a direct threat to our democracy and
regrettably we're seeing it take form in
the in the in the face of political
violence that's potentially playing out
there's been the threat of it at polling
places we we had I mean again it's not
it's not normal to say that we had
people showing up at polling precincts
while the early voting was going on
completely armed
um and saying that they were there
simply to watch voters go in that's
intimidation it's wrong and it really
does pose I think a very real threat to
our democracy okay Maya Barry we'll
leave it there thank you very much for
taking the time to join us here on Al
Jazeera let's cross over to our
correspondent Gabriel Zonda he's live
for us in Pittsburgh Berg in
Pennsylvania now this is one of the
seats where Democrats were most hopeful
of gaining in the Senate Gabe what are
the results looking like
well we have a little over 50 percent of
the vote in and uh John fetterman the
Democrat has a very narrow lead uh it's
still way too early to make any calls on
this it's just this is going to go on
late into the night here as everyone
pretty much expected however I can tell
you that the fetterman campaign is
looking at the numbers coming in and
they feel pretty positive
and that is because fetterman in some in
some very pro-democrat counties
fetterman seems to be running better
than Joe Biden did two years ago in the
presidential election and on the other
side in deep red counties it appears
that the Republican candidate mehmed Oz
is running a little bit below what
Donald Trump's numbers were in red
counties so
Democrats are looking at that and saying
that's looking pretty good for John
Federman but that's still way too close
to call and with just barely over half
the votes counted we still have a very
long night to go here in Pennsylvania
and let's look at new
new Senate race there the Democrats were
hoping to take a slight lead at least
what's uh what's the result looking like
there
yeah New Hampshire Was a Race that the
Democrats were starting to get a little
bit worried about the incumbent Maggie
Hassan
has a big money advantage over her
Republican opponent there she has a more
than 30 million dollars that she spent
on that race or republican opponent uh
Trump supported uh uh someone who's
never held public office before only had
two million dollars that he was able to
spend and results are coming in and it
looks like Maggie Hassan is doing quite
well has a fairly good lead at this
point with more than half of the ballots
in already and so uh uh Democrats are a
little bit breathing a sigh of relief at
this point is it over no it's not but
the race appeared to be tightening in
the last few weeks here Republicans were
dumping a lot of money into the race in
the last few weeks trying to bolster
boldict the the Republican candidate
there and we're hoping that maybe they
could could pull out a victory in New
Hampshire
still a little too close to call but it
looks like Hassan is on the way where
she could potentially win in New
Hampshire holding that seat for the
Democrats that's a race that could be
called uh fairly soon if the numbers
continue to progress as they have been
in the last hour or so okay well as soon
as it is cooled will we bring it to our
viewers Gabe thanks very much let's go
over now to Madison Wisconsin where we
can speak to Heidi Joe Castro I don't
know what's going on there we've got Ron
Johnson Mandela bonds it's a swing state
Joe Biden managed to flip it in 2020
who's looking to be in a healthy lead
there
that's right they are pretty much tied
neck and neck at this moment with some
58 percent of the votes in that U.S
Senate race now counted we're seeing uh
that Mandela Barnes is in the lead by
fewer than 6 000 points over the
incumbent Republican Ron Johnson and
we'd expect that number to shift as the
night goes on given just how closely and
evenly divided we know that historically
voters in this swing state of Wisconsin
are you know the last two presidential
elections were indeed decided by fewer
than one percentage point and we saw the
enthusiasm as voters were coming to the
polls throughout the day in early voting
there was a turnout of 35 percent higher
in this midterm than the previous
there's another big race in Wisconsin
which is the governor's race at this
moment still too early to call but the
Democratic incumbent Tony Evers has a
slight lead over his Republican
Challenger so those are certainly two
things we're watching but also of
interest of course is the abortion issue
which we know has been a major factor in
every race we're watching tonight but in
the neighboring state of Michigan where
I spent the last few days that was the
one of the top of issues for voters
because voters in Michigan are being
asked whether or not they want to
support protection protecting abortion
and that's a direct ballot measure the
only the only race in this midterm
elections that's directly asking voters
about abortion well so far with about 13
percent of those votes counted it looks
like those who do support abortion
access are in the lead by a comfortable
margin at this point which is in keeping
with what the polls has has been showing
but very interesting to watch there as
certainly the question of how abortion
would influence voters in this election
was top of Mind given that abortions are
are no longer protected by the Federal
Constitution and now it's up to States
and the state of Michigan is answering
how voters feel about it okay Heidi
thanks very much indeed let's go back up
now to Washington DC we can join Alan
Fisher and Capitol Hill I'm just looking
at the house results the house
represents is we've got Republicans on
100 Democrats on 56 I mean that would
seem like quite a lead for Republicans
but they need to get to 210 don't they
to take the majority so it's still a way
to go
218 I beg your pardon I've just been
texting
I've just been texting with a republican
uh operative would probably be the best
way to describe him and I said how's it
looking what do you think and he said
look I don't think the Red Wave is going
to happen I think the best we can hope
for is a good night but there is the
possibility that this could be a
disappointing night for us so that was
quite interesting and we've been looking
at some of the races that were going to
be important if there's going to be a
red wave we talked about Abigail
spanberger down in in Virginia she has
won so that's now confirmed Elaine
Laurier is another Democrat in Virginia
we said that that could be a key seat
she looks as if she might lose that as
an official yet still a lot of postal
votes to be counted there but also
Jennifer Wexler also in Virginia she has
won her seat as well so things not
panning out quite as well for the
Republicans as they particularly in
these key seats another interesting name
is Lauren bobert now if you follow
American politics at all you might
recognize her name she comes from
Colorado she's a congresswoman she has
been very vocal in her protests against
Democrats she has floated the rules in
in the house a number of times and she's
thought to be a darling of the the right
wing of the the Republican Party her
race is too close to call and that is a
real surprise the Republicans would have
been banking on her getting home a
couple of other results from earlier on
Maxwell Alejandro Frost 25 years old he
won in Florida 10 he is the going to be
the youngest member of Congress and the
first member of gen Zed to be elected as
well and another interesting result not
yet confirmed but certainly heading that
way Chuck Grassley is going to win his
senate seat in Iowa he is 89 just to
remind you the Senate when you win your
senate seat it is for six years he is
the senior member of the Senate which
means that he is third in line to the
presidency if anything were to happen to
the the vice president and then the
Speaker of the House Chuck Grassley
would step in but he has won it looks as
if he's going to win his seat in Iowa at
the age of 89 for another six-year term
six years at 89 years old or rather him
than me Alan thanks very much indeed
let's go over to Washington uh stay in
Washington rather and that's where Patty
culhane is going to bring in some more
great chats with her guests
thanks so much Laura it is really
getting to be a confusing night so
helping to break all of this down my
excellent panel Nadia Brown is the
professor of government at Georgetown
University that's here in Washington
Steve Clements familiar face host of the
AL jazeera's the bottom line fabulous
show you should watch he's also the
executive editor of 74 because he
doesn't have enough jobs and James Davis
he's a Republican strategist okay
Grassley we were just talking about
Senator Grassley that one I was watching
paying close attention to because Iowa
right now is in this place where
abortion is being battled in the courts
and and in Kansas we saw abortion it
just it energized women to come to the
polls so abortion is on the ballot with
Grassley because the Republicans have
said they will uh try to make a national
ban
what what happened Nadia where uh I know
you said women can walk at chew gum at
the same time but this is a state where
it's quite possible abortion rights will
be taken away yes this is possible and
not entirely unexpected right but just
because Grassley has won this race
doesn't mean that it's I think it's a
foregone conclusion that abortion rights
and reproductive health is off the table
there are activists in the state who are
working to really Elevate women's voices
they're using other kind of um I'll just
say they have tools at the state level
to try to kind of curtail a federal ban
that might come down the pike
you have to say that's going to happen
it might be a Hail Mary pass but I think
what we don't want to lose sight of is
Grassroots activism and the way that
women have mobilized for centuries
oftentimes is not from the inside
politics but it's from outside James you
wanted to talk about the Grassroots
organization because I mean just three
months ago we were like the Democrats
are fired up the Democrats are and then
it just went
yeah I think at the end of the day you
know everyone gets distracted by these
big campaign ads and the TV ads and
stuff and certainly those have an impact
on on the race that's why people do it
but the hard work is the Grassroots uh
infrastructure and building that
Grassroots organization it's the door
knocks uh AFP action uh affiliated with
Americans for Prosperity they've knocked
on 11 million doors 11 million doors
they've really pivoted more to a very
precise group of boaters they're looking
at all the races up and down the ballot
State legislatures all the way through
the federal races they're they're
looking at a Target Universe of 43
million voters right they've done 11
million door knocks they've done phones
they've done more than 100 million
pieces of direct mail and then they've
decided they're going to own the digital
space really targeting individual voters
who want want me to get out and vote and
two people that can be persuadable in
that swing audience with no spillover
that the T that typical tv ads would get
and so David served up more than 1.5
billion Impressions to that 43 million
people uh and that's just in the digital
space that is 38 Impressions per person
if you did the math in your head it took
me a while I had to use account I I
didn't do the math in my head not at all
uh but what was what what were they
getting fired up about why were people
answering the door you know it people
feel like they are paying more and
getting less we've talked about this
obviously over and over agnosium but
inflation pocketbook issues are what
people are concerned about overall
they're also interested and concerned
about the rise and violent crime that
we've seen in cities across the country
look if Democrats have a hard time
turning out uh voters in in the big
cities uh the Philadelphia's of the
world and Atlanta then that really
changes the landscape of election that's
what Joe Biden and historically uh
Democrats really rely on is the coastal
areas and the big cities but
unfortunately because of inflation
because of the rise in violent crime you
see people voting with their feet
they're leaving these big States they're
moving to places like Florida and places
like Texas why they the quality of life
in these big cities is just not what
they're looking for anymore and I think
you also see with the people who don't
have that Mobility can't pick up and
move right because of family because of
jobs whatever you see them exercising
that vote in The Ballot Box and so it's
going to be you know margins slim
margins but that matters a lot in close
elections and we're going to see some
close elections it looks like so Stephen
I'm so glad you're here because uh I
don't know if our audience knows this
but Steve knows literally every single
person who has any any power any pull
any sway in Washington he texts them
they're they're buds uh
both sides of the aisle on both sides of
the aisle yes that's what makes you so
good so how are you reading this what
are you seeing
well I guess what I'm seeing right now
is when you look at I was at a party
earlier tonight uh sort of pre-midderm
election party and it was a republican
tilting uh Gathering and there was a
strident feeling that they Republicans
were going to win 40 governorships out
of 50. when 240 seats in the house uh uh
and win 54 Senate races as we look at
how things are playing out now we should
remind the audience that we don't know
how all the you know the cards are going
to be played yet but that being said
those results are basically unachievable
right now so it's going to be less at
some level than that and we see dynamics
that are really interesting and unusual
that you wouldn't see if it was a major
Red Wave we have two likely female
lesbian Governors that are likely to win
one in Massachusetts one potentially in
Oregon we have the first transgendered
man who just won the first time in U.S
history in New Hampshire New Hampshire
is not a liberal State it's a state with
a lot of confusing currents but you've
got a first trans gendered man who has
won in a state House of Representatives
so there are interesting trends that we
weren't paying much attention to but on
the broader issue of abortion it's
something I find very different between
the Republican uh and Democratic parties
Republicans have been focused like a
laser beam on the Supreme Court and the
justices in this country almost
single-mindedly focused on making sure
that uh they achieved that and they knew
that the objective was to get a reversal
on abortion on Roe v Wade Democrats have
been concerned about this for decades
but Democrats never took the court issue
as seriously as Republicans were
distracted by many other grievances that
they were doing and and behaving that
while the abortion decision really did
impact politics of this country it was
short-lived because the Democrats were
distracted by other big issues including
Republicans but it faded much as it as
it did before that there wasn't the same
kind of focus so I'm not surprised that
it faced but I do think that we're
facing a very difficult I'm in the in
the country as we look at how this plays
out of of again living in two Nations
one nation where women have certain
rights that are embedded in their state
constitutions and protection and other
places where anything that tilts towards
abortion becomes a criminal uh act and I
think that is something that this nation
is not going to solve tonight and is
going to be an ongoing ulcer uh for many
years that's so fun that's really that's
that's really fun thanks Steve I feel
uplifted so sort of a schizophrenic
result right we're seeing well that's
all of these Progressive candidates that
you wouldn't expect to do well but then
the same time you've got Ron DeSantis
who goes I mean Ron DeSantis is the Red
Wave the Red Wave is in Florida yeah and
Donald Trump is trying to clobber Ron
DeSantis right away because he now sees
him as the most powerful force in the in
the Republicans so I guess we should
just wrap it up and say weird times but
we'll see to see how how it goes from
here her but for that's the latest from
Washington for now back to you and Paddy
that's what we like we like weird times
it keeps it interesting thanks very much
well the Republicans have been making
some gains in the house the Democrats
have performed above expectations as we
just heard from Patty there do stay with
us here on altazira for ongoing coverage